many things you see online are not what
they appear to be take the case of
social media influencers people who are
paid to promote brands and products well
some influencers you find in social
media feeds are not real people it's
actually a growing trend some of these
computer-generated influencers have more
than 1 million followers each 22 copal
looks at the issues around these AI
figures Tony good morning good morning
starting to think you can't believe
everything you see online but recent
studies predict the influencer marketing
space will be a 2 billion dollar
industry by 2020 the goal of these
computer-generated influencers to get
you to buy products or experiences now
critics are worried you could be
deceived by a false image they say
seeing is believing but actually what
you're seeing defies that logic little
Michaela modeling's latest dead girl is
an optical illusion
she's an avatar designed by artists and
built by computers and so is shoo-doo
dubbed the world's first digital
supermodel she who was inspired by a
Bobbi doll she just became super popular
London photographer and designer Cameron
James Wilson is the human behind the
avatar CGI and 3d models offer a way for
us to explore or create things that
we've never ever seen before they're
like how can we explore beauty in a
world that's only limited by the
physical things around us with close to
a hundred and twenty-five thousand
followers shoo-doo is also a virtual
influencer just last week Shooto debuted
her first fashion editorial with Women's
Wear Daily
but Cameron says he or she were not paid
like a human fashion model would be we
are blurring the lines between fiction
and reality attorney David Pogue our
studies the ethics of Technology and
says the FTC needs to have guidelines
for CGI influencers the impetus is on
the legislative branch to say maybe we
need better transparency there's been a
lot of discussion about technology
moving at a much faster pace than then
the law has been able to catch up what
do you think could go wrong with CGI
models if it is a fictional character
that a consumer doesn't know if it's
real then to a large extent that
actually not a person that's just an
extended brand so I think what we would
have to worry about is should there be
transparency that would be needed about
the interaction with that brand and
little Michaela is a fast-growing brand
the AI model slash musician has over 1.2
million followers and is growing as an
influencer sporting and promoting
designer clothes her creator a robotics
and AI company called brood has
maintained an allure of anonymity with a
few clicks you sew it together virtually
it's a lot easier than real life it's
clicking instead of like cutting your
hands ryan tang is the vice president of
Clos the company behind the 3d software
used to digitize the clothes on these
virtual models everyone has their own
take of what they think their reality
should look like 3d just kind of gives
the extra step to increase your
creativity for that reality while CGI
models is a first for their company tank
says fashion has been blurring lines for
years with digital garments there's a
lot of 3d going on that no one knows
about when a person goes online to shop
for clothes are the models real people
and are the clothes real so the person's
real but the garment is it so mostly
it's websites you go to you see this guy
who has the same goofy face and
different poses but he's wearing
multiple garments that kind of answers
your question at what point does this
cross over into lying I don't feel like
it's dishonest I think it still does the
job of what it was supposed to do you're
not getting a fake garment when it comes
and it's become a part of the supply
chain that every company actually needs
I think this is the year when you start
noticing that more people are utilizing
those assets so she do and Michaela are
the beginning of something new I think
so and they're gonna be the leaders by
far the first ever do what they're doing
they're not the last they're not the
last for sure and Michaela has proven
she's here to stay in March she posed
for free in New York's Fashion magazine
V wearing luxury brands like for Sachi
Fendi and Chanel
Michaela is just an interesting subject
and I think a really interesting
conversation right now is is again about
the authenticity in this digital age how
much of what's out there content-wise is
real associate editor Devin Barrett sees
a bright future for virtual models
brands ultimately want to be involved in
an interesting story in a story that
gets traction otherwise it's just
product at the end
as for shoe do's creator he says his
digital model is just the start of a new
wave of CGI influencers the influences
of today are changing they realizing
that they need actual engaging content
there's so many different aspects of
this I think and engage and captivate
people for now CGI influencers don't
pose a threat to human influencers but
there are concerns over unrealistic
dimensions of these computer generated
models could fuel a debate about body
image you know there's a guy model and I
definitely I take a look at him and I
think I couldn't fit into those clothes
well we have an entire system that that
conveys importance on what is fake right
and people can buy fake Twitter
followers many people just have fake
Twitter followers there's something
called Twitter audit where you can see
how many to take and so before marketers
start putting money behind this they
should check to see and Twitter should
do a good job - about cleaning out these
files it can be found yeah and while
we're at it some photos of real humans
are photoshopped so much that they
basically look like avatars anyway it's
all virtual reality on social media yeah
well and even on more than social media
and brand magazines well they're both
very pretty I'll say that they're
gorgeous girls as long as you know
they're not real thank you Tony